[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu vous parler d'architecturé
comme d'habitude on entend parler
d'architecturé en cas de catastrophe
naturelle type séisme ou d'inondation et
que je n'ai pas l'intention de créer une
catastrophe pour vous parler d'
architecture il m'a semblé préférable de
revenir à ce que l'architecturé était
capable de générer c'est-à-dire de
capacité à créer à générer des espaces a
qualifié d espace à générer des espaces
de vie et à générer un cadre de vie et
pour bien parler de ça finalement de ce
cadre de vie m'a semblé qu'il était
intéressant de parler d'habitat
participatif et de logement social alors
le logement social je pense qu' un
certain nombre d'entre vous savent ce
que c'est ne serait ce que parce que il
faut rappeler que 70% de la population
française est en mesure de demander un
logement social
d'un point de vue des revenus donc ça
touche une grande partie de la
population l'habitat social
c'est un bailleur social c'est à dire en
fait une sorte de promoteurs qui à un
moment a créé a construit a fait
construire un immeuble
et puis qui va surtout le gérer le louer
et le gérer à des gens dont les niveaux
de ressources ont en tout cas en dessous
d'un certain seuil si ce n'est très bas
pour certains l'habitat participatif est
certainement moins connus puisque
l'habitat participatif cc moins de 1% de
la construction en france
on l'appelle aussi habitat coopératif ou
habitat groupé l'habitat participatif et
effet de façon à ce que les gens
puissent partager des espaces donc des
espaces de vie des espaces communs à la
base c'est des gens comme nous ici
qui se poseront la question de la façon
de vivre dans leur logement et donc à
partir de là il constate souvent que sur
le marché de l'immobilier finalement
d'une certaine manière il ne trouve pas
le logement qu'il aurait adapté
du coup ils trouvent d'autres personnes
qui ont fait la même démarche
et puis ils vont se mettre ensemble ils
vont faire une première réunion puis une
deuxième puis une troisième
ça peut durer un certain temps de façon
à concevoir un projet collectif en
général l'habitat participatif à deux
grands objectifs
on retrouve souvent de ces deux grands
objectifs dans l'habitat participatif
que sont d'un côté la création des
espaces communs de vie et de l'autre
côté la réponse à un certain nombre
d'enjeux écologiques
alors pour illustrer tout ça je vais
vous montrer maintenant des au projet
c'est des projets auxquels j'ai
participé
j'ai préféré choisir cela parce que
c'est ce que je connais le mieux pour
l'ensemble ces projets il y à une
multitude d'acteurs déjà l'équipe dans
laquelle j'étais en tant que maître
d'oeuvre en fait de ces projets il ya
les maîtres d'ouvragé qui sont en fait
les personnes qui ont demandé à
construire évidemment ces bâtiments
donc les groupes en question par exemple
dans le cas de l'habitat participatif
l'ensemble de ses secteurs de ses
acteurs pour une question de
présentation
vous les trouverez si vous le souhaitez
donc sur la plateforme
tadic sujet premier projet un projet en
ville de cinq logements
donc comme on peut le voir l'habitat
participatif à la fin c'est la fête
c'est une opération
mais avant d'arriver là il s'est passé
plusieurs années alors larchitecture va
formaliser sous formes spatiales les
attentes de ses habitants
les attentes sont deux
ordre donc je dis espaces comme un enjeu
écologique mais il ne faut pas oublier
quelque chose qui est plus personnel qui
est quand même que chacun va avoir un
logement individuel qui lui est propre
en fait ce n'est pas une nouvelle forme
de communautarisme il est bien question
d'un vivre ensemble
mais négocier où on a sa part d'un team
et sa part de collectif on peut voir
outre l'utilisation du jardin par le
groupe qu'il ya dans ce projet au rez de
chaussée en jaune une salle commune qui
va permettre des activités propres à
l'immeuble aux habitants de cet immeuble
mais qui va aussi pouvoir s'ouvrir sur
l'extérieur pour accueillir par exemple
une amap ou des réunions d'une
association de quartier on va trouver au
deuxième étage une grande terrasse en
verre sous forme de l et puis un studio
en bleu le studio permettant
d'accueillir la famille des amis et
évitant d'avoir à créer chacun dans
chacun des logements des appartements
une chambre supplémentaire
comme je disais précédemment ce n'est
pas un projet qui est tourné que sur le
collectif donc l'idée est bien que dans
chaque logement il y a aussi les
qualités des espaces de lumières de
couleurs d'ambiance qui soit propre à
chaque habitant en tout cas à chaque
famille
donc là on a à cinq logements et cinq
façons de voir son logement est d'avoir
une configuration qui nous qui nous est
propre
un deuxième projet qui montre que ne
serait ce que par l'image extérieure
on peut produire des formes urbaines
donné au quartier à la ville des
ambiances différentes
dans ce cas là on est un peu plus sur
deux petites maisons individuelles
qui seraient regroupés par une cage
d'escalier il n'y a pas de salle
collective et parce que l'architecturé
l'architecte doit aussi savoir se mettre
en retrait parfois puisque les habitants
de ces quatre logements ont décidé de
construire d'auto construire leur salle
commune sur un autre morceau du terrain
en revanche on peut aussi parler des
enjeux écologiques puisqu'on voit en
toiture de couleur bleue qui simule en
fait des panneaux solaires thermiques
permettant de faire du chauffage solaire
et des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
permettent de produire de l'électricité
dans le cas du projet précédent les
enjeux écologiques on va dire était en
partie résolu par une chaudière au bois
un troisième exemple mais cette fois-ci
de logement social dans ce cadre là on
est beaucoup plus contre 1 puisque au
moment de la conception du projet on n'a
pas les habitants sous la main par
définition on a un maître d'ouvragé un
bailleur social et c'est lui qui va nous
donner un cahier des charges et ce
cahier des charges
il est tel qu'il permet normalement
d'accueillir le plus grand nombre
d'entre nous donc en fait c'est une un
cahier des charges tourner autour d'une
architecture un peu banalisé
donc l'idée pour les architectes qui
considère que le cadre de vie et le
vivre ensemble est important va être de
se saisir de petits détails d'éléments
techniques parfois pour arriver à faire
émerger une qualité au projet alors déjà
ce projet c'est des activités au
rez-de-chaussée et du logement aux trois
niveaux supérieurs en fait c'est un
bâtiment pour les hypocondriaques parce
qu'il suffit de prendre l'ascenseur et
hop on peut aller chez le médecin à la
pharmacie ou celle qui naît
dans ce bâtiment la seule chose qu'on
avait à disposition
c'était en fait les coursives c'est à
dire des espaces de circulation qui
relient les différents logements et ses
espaces de circulation
en général on cherche plutôt à les
diminuer parce que ben la surface ça
coûte de l'argent et que l'argent on n'a
pas beaucoup donc on essaye de les
diminuer
mais nous a semblé intéressant pour
créer justement un vivre ensemble
puisque on ne pouvait pas créer deux
salles communes de blanc dry commune de
d'ateliers de et cetera
on a donc décidé d'élargir ses espaces
et de leur donner des qualités on voit
ici la possibilité par exemple pour les
enfants des différentes familles d'être
à la fois dehors puisque ses coursives
sont ouvertes et d'être pas dans la rue
pour autant donc en assurant aussi une
certaine sécurité et une certaine
surveillance
alors bien sûr les projets qu'on vient
de voir son des projets qui ont été
construits en neuf mais il est possible
aussi de faire de la rénovation
on a là un exemple d'un immeuble début
du 20e siècle et à nouveau on va
travailler vraiment à la marge
c'est à dire que dans une cage
d'escalier là où passent les gens et où
ils se croisent on va essayer de donner
des qualités qui vont faire qu'ils vont
avoir envie de ceux restés de discuter
d'échanger
ça peut être dans un passage couvert
ça peut être dans un hall d'entrée on
voit ici le bâtiment donc qui est à
grenoble en fait cours berriat qui est
en fait un ancien hôtel un hôtel qui
avait été construit au début du xxème
pour accueillir les visiteurs de la
foire internationale sur la houille
blanche
et puis la vie faisant cet hôtel est
resté des années inutilisés et puis un
bailleur social a décidé de le reprendre
et de le rénover
on trouve donc une dizaine de logements
et au rez de chaussée une possibilité
d'activer
et alors une fois qu'on a parlé
d'habitat participatif et de logement
social on a envie de mixer les deux
parce que d'un côté
dans l'habitat participatif on est
plutôt sur un système d'accession
même si ce système peut être plus
coopératif que ça à travers les
coopératives d'habitants et du côté de
l'habitat social
on est plutôt sur un système de location
même si la hausse il existe de
l'accession sociale
donc il va y avoir des gens qui sont sur
différents systèmes
ne serait-ce que aussi par le niveau de
revenu ou par question de choix qui
préfèrent rester dans un système plutôt
que dans un autre
mais qui ont par contre comme objectif
commun de pouvoir avoir des activités de
groupe et faire des choses ensemble
là on a un projet de 13 logements avec
neuf logements qui sont a priori pour le
groupe d'habitat participatif et quatre
logements porté par un bailleur social
évidemment les espaces communs on
retrouve en fait dans le tableau au rez
de chaussée vont servir à l'ensemble des
habitants in fine est juste eu ce qui
est intéressant dans le tableau c'est ce
qui est en orange c'est à dire que les
espaces communs représente en fait un
tiers des surfaces totale construite
donc c'est pas du tout négligeable en
fait dans la façon de vide dans deux
bâtiments on va retrouver bien sûr une
salle comme une chambre d'amis un
atelier une buanderie mais aussi ce
qu'on a nommé palier qu'on devrait
d'ailleurs renommé requalifier parce que
ces paliers de 50 m² à chaque niveau
soit en fait prévue pour permettre aux
gens de se rencontrer d'échanger et
d'avoir des activités à chaque niveau
vous l'aurez compris à travers ses
projets il n'est pas question de parler
d'une architecture futuriste mais l'idée
c'était de vous montrer qu'avant de
construire avant de dessiner avant de
concevoir des espaces
il est vraiment important pour nous tous
de se poser la question de la façon dont
on veut vivre dans son logement avec les
logements qui sont à proximité voire
même au sein de son quartier et ensuite
à travers l' architecture
on peut effectivement résoudre un
certain nombre de contraintes résoudre
les enjeux écologiques et résoudre le
vivre ensemble
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]